was bedeutet dass ein mensch zu sein und
schmerzen zu haben
was bedeutet es zu leben anna lisa ist
eine liebesgeschichte und zwar eine
liebesgeschichte aus der sicht eines
etwas verquollenen leim side rischen
abgewirtschafteten motivationssprüche
der so durch die welt fährt und für den
alle menschen gleich aussehen und auch
gleich klingen bis diese eine person in
sein leben tritt eben lisa die anomalie
deswegen ist der film allemal isa die
alles anders macht für ihn
hallo
schlimm aus ich habe mich gerade
abgeschminkt mein gott nein sie sehen
bezauberndes das entscheidende was ganz
anders ist in diesem film als bei vielen
anderen filmen sind die darstellenden
personen sind nämlich keine personen
sondern puppen ungefähr so groß wie die
hand spanne
und was die machen ist etwas das bei der
produktion des films geste für geste
dänische entscheidung für misch
entscheidung mit den händen manipuliert
das heißt es hat sehr lange gedauert
wahrscheinlich das ding zu drehen aber
es ist dem thema sehr adäquat weil
liebesgeschichte natürlich geschichten
sind in den einzelnen sekunden einzelne
momente einzelne blicke extrem
entscheidende funktionen haben ich habe
sich außergewöhnlich
das weiß ich nicht ich weiß nur mit
sicherheit dass es so ist und man die
ganze zeit denkt es könnte auch unter
fallen könnte zerbrechen könnte
schiefgehen
und dieses zittern bei gleichzeitigem
weiterfließen der geschichte bildet der
film wahnsinnig schön ab bis in den
sound rhein bis in die unschärfen rein
es ist tatsächlich ein theaterstück
sowie der liebe gott uns vielleicht als
theaterstück sieht der mensch neben
ihnen hat schon einen tag hinter sich
manchmal bei dieser tat gut manchmal
schlecht als erstes signal dass man es
hier mit dem film zu tun hat er anders
ist als die filme die man in meinem
beruf die ganze zeit sehen darf oder
auch muss war tatsächlich die
pressevorführung bei der selbst die
notorischen dauer lacher und von sich
reden machen und sich bemerkbar mache
die man halt kennt in den verschiedenen
städten vorhanden sind
irgendwann muss es verstehen einfach aus
dem grund weil der film sich teilweise
so weit zurück zieht dass man ihm folgen
werden dass man reingezogen und
außerhalb von jurek lesung die dann aber
wieder aus anderen gründen gerne mal
langweilig werden habe ich diese art von
spannung ganz ganz selten
entschuldigung ich habe ihre hand
gehalten ist okay es ist ein reflex
nicht fliegen ich gern ich sagte okay
allerdings können sie jetzt loslassen